I love like you're welcome to my show
anytime cuz you brought cake and wine
which are to be okay isn't something
special fun cake
yes you tell us about your cake and I'm
gonna tell you how good this - Oh what
do you like cake I do now yes yes I will
go to town on cake and wine all day well
that's a bundt cake and I always hated
blood cakes because they were that
ordinary bunch shape you know the ones
that that just they don't look like this
and then we came up with some new bundt
cake pans
okay fan and yeah it's no deep the
beautiful design is on that you can ice
in between those it does look like
architecture yeah it does it's just so
beautiful and they're all different
kinds of sizes and shapes now with a bun
the bundt cake so this is our newest one
we made we do
oh isn't that good that is yours that's
our league okay it's really good that's
a way burgundy a lesser burden yeah I
call it but it's from the Burgundy
region of France and I curate wine I
like security
I choose one I don't do that attempts I
love French oh there's there's so many
good wines in the world but but I find
that most people don't know how to
choose a good wine so I do all the
choosing I have all the fun I date so
many wines we thought we'd taste
hundreds of wines a month to choose just
a few very good ones oh my god we can
sell it if you ever need someone to help
you with that know what you doing
and let's see how this cuts oh my God
look how fluffy really nice I mean who
doesn't like cake
that's a whipped cream pound cake cream
you mind if I serve yes I think we need
a cappuccino or I love a cappuccino but
why we're in this moment can I walk yeah
wait taste a little piece just to make
sure it's delicious okay oh my god
there's not enough later though you're
doing a Thanksgiving dinner demo so how
do you celebrate Thanksgiving oh well we
usually have a big thing skipping maybe
for 40 people or so everybody wants to
come to my house cuz I raised me I
raised my own turkeys sure and we have
so we have heritage breeds you know what
here in the three turkeys are no but I'm
sure they taste great and so I do three
turkeys three different ways and you do
three different turkey oh yeah three
different different ways I love that you
said oh yeah like that's not 40 people
you need three true okay I got you
they're like 25 pounds each and so we're
doing a turkey and parchment wrapped in
parchment so you start off baking it
just at a low temperature and then you
raise the temperature when you take the
paper off and it gets all nice and
glossy brown skin and we get spatchcock
spatchcock turkey ever do a spatula what
I'm just realizing that they're three
different ways to do turkey what did you
see there many more than three we
spatchcock you you
that's nothing dirty it's nothing dirty
it doesn't it out it means split the
[ __ ] the [ __ ] weights of a rooster
what it means is you take out the
backbone with a pair of scissors thread
it flat and it cooks in like a third of
the time that's so for those of you who
are oven
you know oven poor if you only have one
oven you have to bake the pies you have
to do all the sides have to do the
turkey so you ever show it one shot wine
and I'm already owe me two I just see
you do have a show with Snoop Dogg which
I love I've seen and I think it's
hilarious
but I also heard you might be launching
a CVD line oh I am working with canopy
the big company up in Canada yeah they
they actually hybridize and grow
cannabis and they're also doing now hemp
in a big way so so I working only in CBD
I do not touch cannabis you don't touch
th oh not like Snoop
[Laughter]
very feelings like Stephen is very
healing us while CBD is different
property yeah it's so many and I'm
working on not only food products but
also skincare as well as pet products
that's great for my dog I will not stop
talking until you subscribe to my
youtube channel that's right and I could
talk a lot seriously not gonna stop yep
still here not going anywhere I see you
don't walk away from this